hey guys should men chase women
here's what a few influential people say
um I would say two young men who are
irritated at women is if you're
irritated at women you know as a class
of creature there's something wrong with
you because they're right you're wrong
they're right
to not pick you if they're not picking
you it's because they're right
wow now that might get I know that's a
terrible thing to say and I know
perfectly well
it wasn't like I was particularly
successful with girls when I was young
don't chase women
chase your dreams if you successfully
manage to check those dreams the women
will come now the second reason men
shouldn't chase women is because you
come across as desperate and sometimes
even pathetic especially when the
feeling is not mutual but understand and
that in most cases when a man is chasing
after a woman it's not a good look on
him and he starts to lose the respect of
that woman when you are made to have to
chase after her initially you are
typically going to end up in a
relationship where the onus is always on
you to make more of an effort where she
is always on such a high of a pedestal
that is expected for you to make it work
for you to do this for you to do that
where she gets to sit back and wait if a
woman makes you chase there's only two
reasons why in my opinion this is
happening reason number one she's not
that interested in you second reason why
a woman will make you chases because she
has her walls up she's been hurt she's
been through some stuff before so
essentially there's some emotional
damage there and because of that she
wants you to show her enough enough for
her to feel safe to now put herself out
there so you're pursuing someone you're
interested in versus with chasing you're
chasing someone who isn't interested in
you so I hope that that kind of
highlights the difference between the
two you might think I need her to like
me and you come across very desperate
and needy in your Chase and the reason
why this is such an issue is because
you're chasing someone who is not
interested in you that is why it's
called chasing when you're chasing
something it means that it's running
away from you or it doesn't want to be
caught which in return is just a
complete waste of your time and you know
that's the witchy part of women and
that's the part that's attractive
attractive attractive but rejecting
rejecting rejecting and so many men are
petrified by women they won't approach
them at all they have no idea how to
talk to them they're just petrified into
immobility and that's way more common
than you think and so that breeds
resentment like you wouldn't believe you
know you know it's then that's the
problem too if you're chronically
rejected by people people it's often
because of your own insufficiencies you
know whether that's cowardice or lack of
social skills or whatever it is it's
like you can't just brush it off as oh
well you know no one likes me but really
I'm okay it's like no no wrong if
everyone rejects you there's probably
something wrong and it's probably deep
and difficult and it's going to be
horrible to fix all right so let's talk
about this and just so you know just
because I show you certain clips of
certain people it doesn't mean that I
agree with everything they say on their
Channel but most of them are right when
it comes to saying you shouldn't chase
after women
depending whether you understand what it
actually means when people say chasing
after women and let me start here first
if you might be one of those men who get
angry when women reject you
you need to ask yourself these questions
first would you date you
do you have good manners
do you dress well or are you sloppy
[Music]
do you groom yourself and smell good
are you a man of integrity of good
character
can you offer her a stable and secure
future
[Music]
foreign
answers for some of those questions then
I can understand why women will reject
you you see you need to start working on
yourself first
instead of chasing after women because
if you become the right man the right
type of woman will find you so I can
understand certain women out there when
I look at certain guys of course they
should be careful
will they allowed into their lives I
mean they can get pregnant you can't and
too many guys these days
unfortunately just think about sex all
the time instead of thinking about
becoming the right man and getting the
right woman to marry first and to create
a stable home and then to have kids
according to statistics close to 70
percent of relationships fail within the
first year while 40 of marriages end in
divorce
and according to the U.S Census Bureau
more than one in four children live
without a father in a home
you know men without a backbone they
just have one out stance and then they
run away they don't take responsibility
and they don't care
I mean for me that is just pure evil and
we are guys right so let me be straight
with you let's be honest here how many
of you guys listening to this video
actually wished that you had a dad at
home
when you while you were growing up a
good father that we're there for you
you see we need more men of good
character of integrity
who takes care of their responsibilities
we don't just run away when a woman gets
pregnant
no
Proverbs 20 7 says the righteous who
walks in his Integrity
blessed are his children after him you
know there are some guys out there who
women are afraid of for good reason
guys who just think who create this
image in their head wow she looks
beautiful I want to have her and that's
it they don't think further than that
do you hear what I'm saying she's an
image an idea in your own head instead
of being an individual and a lot of
people who are addicted to it
pornography do exactly the same thing
it's an image it's a it's just a prop
it's not an individual a person
and here's the thing she can only become
an individual to you if you actually
care about her have a conversation with
her to get to know her instead of just
thinking about sex see as Lewis said
love is not an affectionate feeling but
a steady wish for the loved person's
ultimate good as far as it can be
obtained
so a lot of guys need to understand the
difference between an idea of just a
woman you know an icon or or just the
idea of her the image you have in your
head and who she really actually is
meaning a lot of guys choose the wrong
woman they chase after her and they're
so fixated on her the idea of her that
they don't even see who she really is
and you don't realize that she's
actually not a good fit for you at all
this is called the halo effect the halo
effect is a type of cognitive bias in
which our overall impression of a person
influences how we feel and think about
their character
so should you chase after a woman
here's my advice never chase a woman who
don't want to be with you
never chase a woman who wants you to
chase her because she wants to feel sexy
and good about herself and not because
she really cares about you never chase a
woman with bad morals
never chase a woman with a lot of
psychological issues
never chase a woman who is extremely
worldly and who has low self-control
never chase a woman who is only
interested in your money
and never chase a woman who always want
to control you
never chase a woman period
instead pray to God to send you the
right woman
because you know the day and age that we
live in a lot of people which of course
includes women are extremely selfish and
vain
and also very arrogant and that makes
relationships extremely difficult
and God said that this would happen 2
Timothy 3 verse 1. but understand this
that in the last days there will come
times of difficulty for people will be
lovers of self lovers of money proud
arrogant abusive disobedient to their
parents ungrateful Unholy heartless
unappeasable slanderous without
self-control brutal not loving good
treacherous Reckless swollen with
conceit lovers of pleasure rather than
lovers of God
having the appearance of godliness but
denying its power
avoid such people
do not chase after women who are like
this avoid them at all costs because
here's the thing sometimes you will not
just you won't think clearly because of
your subject of brain as full of
testosterone she might look like a model
on the outside but inwardly she might be
more like a monster that's going to suck
all the life out of you
and you know there's only a few
just a few very I mean extremely
important decisions
that you have to make in your whole life
the most important decision is choosing
Jesus Christ as your lord and savior to
receive eternal life because that has
Eternal consequences right not just
temporary worldly consequences the
second decision on this life for this
life
is who you choose as a partner
a wife because you will spend the rest
of your life with her and that's why you
need to pray about it because you cannot
see the unknown future but you can trust
God who you know because he knows the
future
and he already knows man
this is the woman this is the virtuous
woman that is a good fit for John for
Peter you need to choose wisely
because she will change you one
Corinthians 15 33 do not be deceived Bad
Company ruins good morals imagine if you
choose the wrong woman and you promise
that you would spend the rest of your
life with her for good and for Worse
you did not just only promise that to
her but to God
marriage is sacred proverbs 31 verse 10
an excellent wife who can find she is
far more precious than jewels
and you know just so you know that this
is not just a story that I'm making up I
prayed for Nikita as well
I heard stories from other people men
who pray to God for a good woman a good
virtuous woman and they waited patiently
they still went to church they went to
Bible studies they went to have coffee
at places to the park and wherever they
met the person they knew they had peace
in their hearts from the holy spirit
this is your wife one day and they got
married and they're still happy to this
day
don't chase after a woman but you can
pursue a woman if God leads you to
gently
this is important to understand
for example you met her at the park and
then you don't know if you're gonna ever
see her again so then you maybe just ask
her number ask if you can have a coffee
don't push her or just chase her and no
take it easy move forward within the
rest of God just move in his peace with
his Direction now I also want to talk
about many guys who are shy
and they are shy because they are scared
of rejection that's the root of the
problem they're scared of rejection
but if God leads you to do it you need
to overcome that fear because God has
not given us a spirit of fear but of
power of love and self-control and the
only way to overcome that fear is to act
in faith now just my last advice to you
pray to God let him lead the right woman
to you and then marry the woman who
loves God a lot more than she would ever
love any man proverbs 31 verse 10 says
an excellent wife who can find she has
far more precious than Jewels the heart
of her husband trusts in her and he will
have no lack of gain she does him good
and not harm all the days of her life
verse 15 she Rises while it is yet night
and provides food for her household and
portions for her maidens verse 17 she
dresses herself with strength and makes
her arms strong she perceives that her
merchandise is profitable her lamp does
not go out at night
verse 20 she opens her hand to the poor
and reaches out her hands to the needy
verse 25 strength and dignity are her
clothing and she laughs at the time to
come
she opens her mouth with wisdom and the
teaching of kindness is on her tongue
she looks well to the ways of her
household and does not eat the bread of
idleness her children rise up and call
her blessed her husband also and he
Praises her
many women have done excellently but you
surpass them all charm is deceitful and
beauty is vain but a woman who fears the
Lord is to be praised
you see this is clearly a type of woman
that any guy would love to marry
forget about sex and lust and all the
things that the world keeps on throwing
at men today
think further than that find a Godly
woman
and be a Godly Man
that is the most important
and for you young men out there who are
still unmarried
focus on improving yourself to become a
man of God and then you will find a
right woman
and also focus on what the true meaning
of love really is
one Corinthians 13 verse 4 love is
patient and kind love does not envy or
boast
it is not arrogant or rude it does not
insist on his own way it is not
irritable or resentful it does not
rejoice at wrongdoing but rejoices with
the truth love bears all things believes
all things hopes all things endures all
things
you didn't read hear that love is just
sex or lust did you the Bible talks
about four different kinds of love and
when it comes to the relationship of
marriage a man and a woman it is the
only relationship where all four types
are present you have era's love which is
sexual attraction sexual love but then
you also have agape love which is
unconditional love
which means you have to love her even if
you don't feel like it in your flesh you
still love her right
then you have storge family love which
is empathy understanding love but then
you also have friendship love and that
is called phileo
so
if you want more information if you want
to grow as a person as a man to become
the right man
and watch this playlist here that will
help you to improve yourself and I'll
see you there and always remember life
is short so don't waste yours cheers
guys